this is a production of Cornell
University thank you on you so the last
two years I've been working on this
project for my master's thesis with the
Cornell small farms program so my
research has been on using black plastic
tarps on the surface of the soil prior
to planting to suppress weeds and make
reduce tillage more viable in organic
vegetable systems to outline this
project I'm going to first start out
with a bit of background so how is
plastic already used in vegetable
systems kind of get into what organic
vegetable systems are what they entail
and then how does tillage fit into this
and why should we reduce it then I'll
get into what is a tarp why when how do
you use a tarp and what questions was I
trying to answer with this research I'll
then get into the data and the results
of the experiment looking first at how
tarps impact the soil environment and
then how it tarps impact weeds and crop
yield there's time at the end I'll get
into some of the farm trials that I've
been working on so I had four on-farm
trials at some local farms within the
region that actually implemented this
project onto their farms prefers to
start with a bit of background so
plastic and agriculture is not a new
thing farmers use plastic in a variety
of different ways on their farms
solarization and plastic mulch film are
the two ways that are most similar to
tarps so I'm going to be getting into
those in more detail in the next couple
of slides tarps can also be used for
fumigation so that's putting tarps on a
surface of the soil and injecting a gas
such as methyl ethyl bromide or other
things like that that will kill all
pathogens under the tarp plastic is also
used as bro covers which is put over
crops and protects them from insects or
they can be used in low tunnels such as
on the bottom or high tunnels like on
the top to increase temperatures and
extend the growing season on a farm
plastic can even be used as a covering
or heated greenhouses so let's look a
bit more closely at solarization
solarization is the use of clear plastic
polyethylene on the sir
of the soil in times of high heat and
high sunlight this concentrates the heat
in the sunlight and kills weeds and weed
seeds under the tarps if it's hot enough
it can even kill pathogens or nematodes
under it as well but if you look at
where this is done so Jordan Italy
Pakistan Syria Turkey and the warmer
states of the United States need extreme
temperatures to make this work if you
look here at the average temperatures
under these solarization tarps they
range from a hundred degrees Fahrenheit
up to 140 degrees Fahrenheit so first of
all this has to be done in the summer
which can interfere with cropping plans
and second of all if these temperatures
don't reach high enough temperatures
that can actually promote weed growth so
if you use solarization in a place like
the Northeast you may actually promote
weeds by creating a sort of mini
greenhouse on the surface of the soil
you increase heat you increase moisture
and they still have that we still have
sunlight so this is not really a viable
practice in the Northeast black plastic
mulch is extremely common in the
Northeast it's a very thin polyethylene
plastic about one to two mil and you
have to have specialized equipment to do
this you use a bed former which
stretches this plastic mulch over your
beds and buries the edges and you
actually plant crops into this as you
can see here so this plastic mulch stays
on the surface of the soil throughout
the entire growing season it suppresses
weeds it increases temperature and it
preserves moisture farmers will
typically put drip tape underneath this
to irrigate their crops so as you can
see here there is no in-between row
control of weeds for this system and
this is very thin so it is not reusable
it will degrade it will tear throughout
the course of the season and you
actually have to pull this up and get
rid of it at the end of the growing
season so why would you use these sort
of strange methods with plastic in
agriculture and how does this relate to
tillage well first let's look at organic
systems so if you've lived in Ithaca for
any period of time you've seen the
success and the growth of organics in
consumer
like farmers markets and grocery stores
things like that so the number of small
farms small organic farms in the
Northeast that grow diversified
vegetables is growing rapidly and these
farms have a lot of unique challenges
and probably the biggest challenge that
these organic farmers face is weed
control these organic farmers cannot use
pesticides so that instead they have to
use cultural control practices to get
rid of weeds
these can include crop rotation flame
weeding cover crops plastic as we've
seen but most of all tillage so these
farmers use heavily rely on intensive
tillage to control weeds in their
systems tillage especially is effective
at controlling weeds that have already
emerged and as one of the only ways that
these farmers can get rid of emerged
weeds without using an herbicide so
tillage controls weeds it incorporates
residue from past cover crops or the
crop that was in the season before and
it creates a smooth planting bed in
which the farmers can plant but
intensive tillage degrades soil health
tillage weakened soil structure it
breaks up aggregates it can form surface
sealing it causes compaction increases
erosion and causes moisture loss from
the soil tillage also increases aeration
and warming of the soil which increases
microbial activity and that can cause an
increase in the oxidation of carbon this
does two things first of all this will
put co2 into the atmosphere which is bad
for climate change also this will
decrease the organic matter content of
the soil looking at it from more of a
farmer perspective tillage cost labor
time and fuel so can plastic help with
this if we look back at solarization yes
solarization does help control weeds
which could in turn help farmers reduce
tillage however we saw that solarization
does not work on farms the Northeast
plastic mulch actually requires tillage
so in order to make these beds you have
to tell so while it does decrease weeds
it does not decrease tillage so there's
a gap here how can we use plastic to
decrease tillage
organic vegetable farms in the Northeast
in turn tarps so what is its heart
you've all heard of tarps I'm sure they
cover your baseball fields they protect
your equipment from rainfall and they
can even be used in innovative ways such
as making a sale for a sailboat a
hammock or 25 different survivalist
shelters but for our purposes a tarp is
a piece of a sheet of plastic six mil
black polyethylene so this plastic has
been treated to be resistant to be UV
resistant it is black on at least one
side and ism it is impermeable to water
and air so these are a lot thicker than
plastic mulch which means they're a lot
more durable and they can last multiple
seasons they're cut to cover multiple
crop beds and that includes in between
rows so tarps go on the ground a number
of weeks or even months prior to
planting of cash crops and then the
farmer removes this tarp before planting
their crops so these are some pictures
just showing what a tarp looks like in
an actual vegetable production system
let's get into some logistics of charts
so tarps range in price from around a
hundred dollars to two hundred and
ninety dollars this depends on the size
of the tarp tarps are typically 100 feet
long and 100 feet is pretty much the
standard bed length in a small scale
vegetable farm so that's why they're
that length and then they can range from
24 to 50 feet wide depending on how many
beds you want to cover but the wider the
tarp is the heavier it gets of course
and they can be 75 pounds or even more
when you get up to those really wide
tarps so a lot of the farmers that we've
been working with will actually cut
these types down the smaller size to
make them more manageable because a
gigantic piece of 75 pound plastic on a
windy day is quite unruly they become
giant sales so management can be an
issue but farmers are finding ways
around this
farmers lay these on the surface of the
soil and hold them down using heavy
objects a lot of farmers use sandbags
rocks
or even just shovel fulls of soil I have
heard from some farmers that using the
soil burying method doesn't work as well
and that the wind will rip the tarps up
on a very windy day so we suggest using
the sandbags rocks and concrete in order
to store these tarps a lot of farmers
will actually roll these between beds
and keep them there during the season
and the winter however this does
increase exposure of tarps to the
environment and so in order to get the
most out of the reusability of these
tarps we suggest either storing them in
a barn or a shed or else if you want to
leave them in the field you should at
least cover them with something else to
keep the rain and the sunlight off of
them and the warranty on these is
usually five years but I've heard of
farmers using them ten years or even
more if you're careful to maintain them
so the questions that I was looking at
for tarps tarps are already used pretty
widely in the Northeast but no research
had been done on the mechanisms of how
these parts actually impact the soil how
they actually impact weeds or if they
really do increase yield of crops so the
questions I sought to seek with this
research was how do tarp benefits for
late to tarp duration so is a three-week
tarp versus a 6-week tarp or longer does
that have a difference in the effect it
has on soil weeds and crops do tarp
benefits differ with planting date so if
you put a tarp down in May versus June
versus July does that have a difference
in the impact of these tarps how do
tarps impact the soil environment and
weeds and can tarps actually help reduce
tillage through these mechanisms so to
enter these questions we designed this
experiment I'm first going to show you a
bit of a time layout just to kind of get
in your head because it can be kind of
confusing with the tarp durations so we
had two planting dates one is on top and
one is on bottom we planted an oat cover
crop in August and then we flail mowed
this in November now for the early
planning we put down a 24 week tarp
directly on top of that flail mode
and then if you skip down to when we
actually planted each tarp duration is
the number of weeks before planting so
here we have the three-week type was
three weeks before planning six weeks
before planning and ten weeks before
planting so for our late planting we
actually had a 10-week cover crop
because 20 I'm sorry a 10 week tarp
because the 24 week tarp would have been
in the middle of winter and we can't put
a tarp down on top of snow so for our 10
we had that as a 10 plus week duration
so for the early planting that was 24
weeks for the late planting that was 10
weeks we then removed the tarps and a
few days later we then planted beets and
harvested sheets at the end of the
season so this is a picture on the top
left of the oak cover crop that we mowed
down then you can see we put the tarps
directly on top of that the picture on
the bottom is showing tarps around March
April so this shows more of the
treatments and the tarps later in the
season after we removed tarps we applied
three tillage treatments to see the
interaction between tarps and tillage we
had a Noto which was no disturbance of
the soil except with the planter we had
a reduced toe which was a 1 to 3 inch
shallow till depending on the location
and then we had a conventional toe which
was 48 inches with a roto toe we had
this whole experiment in three locations
so one was in freedo about 20 minutes
away and that is where I've been
conducting my personal research
experiment we also had the same
experiment in Monmouth Maine and in
Riverhead Long Island to see how tarps
impact different climates different soil
types things like that so the actual
depth of tillage did vary by location so
we put them in those groups we then
planted beets as an indicator crop we
chose beets for a variety of reasons one
is that table beets are growing in
popularity in the Northeast two is that
they are a root crops so they show the
effects of soil compaction a lot more
than other crops would they're also
sensitive to nitrogen and to weeds which
made them in a good indicator crap and
they're delicious
so after the end of the season we
harvested the beasts we put them in
different size classes and we weighed
them with fresh weight to estimate yield
so let's get into the data first I'm
going to look at soil environment
effects of tarps and this is mainly from
when the tarps went on the ground
through to planting so starting with
soil temperature tarps were on the
surface of the soil for a wide range of
seasonality and you can see here we put
them on in November when things are
still green they stay through the snow
and then came off in the spring the
temperatures at the time of tarp removal
were about one and a half to ten point
four degrees higher than bare ground but
was this effect only during warm seasons
or was it the entire duration the
temperature sensors were 15 centimeters
so about yeah 6 inches so here's a
sample graph from some Monmouth Maine
data so here we have average soil
temperature in Fahrenheit on the Left on
the bottom it's the various parts of the
season that the tarps were actually on
the soil left we have planting one which
was the early planting and the right we
have planting 2 which was the late
planting so I have these lines down here
and these bicolor and look and placement
show when a tarp was applied so before
the light green three-week tarp applied
for example that tarp was not on the
soil until that line beyond that the
light green indicates temperature under
the tarp and the black line on the
bottom the dotted line that's the bare
soil so as you can see here prior to
around June there was not much pattern
with tarp temperature but once you get
to warmer temperatures around 60 degrees
Fahrenheit tarps it started to increase
the temperature compared with bare soil
so we can find from this is that in the
cold seasons tarps did not really impact
temperature but once they got warm
outside tarps did increase soil
temperature from 1 to 10 degrees and
have a table here showing this is one
day before we remove the tarps we have
free ville Monmouth and Riverhead are
three locations for each of the two
years and planting one and planning two
we have no tarp three week tarp 6 week
tarp and 10 or more week tarp on the
left so in almost all the treatments
except for two temperature did
significantly increase under tarps and I
bolded the widest difference between no
tarp and tarp for each one so you can
see that as temperatures got warmer that
increase got higher so here is the
highest right here this is the warmest
temperatures that ever got under the
tarps we get a 10 degree increase when
it gets warmer
whereas when it's cooler such as here
with the 50s it only increased by 3
degrees so tarps do increased soil
temperatures under the tarps but it
really doesn't have much of an effect
until later in the season and when it's
warm outside soil moisture was not
different between tarp durations so a
three week tarp six week tarp and 10
week tarp did not affect soil moisture
differently but tarp duration of any
length did have higher soil moisture
compared with bare ground so first I'm
going to show the rainfall and
temperature data of the entire two years
that this experiment was in place so the
left side is precipitation and inches
and that's the blue lines the right side
is daily average temperature in
Fahrenheit and that's the red line and
then down here I have each of the tarp
durations so this is the solid lines is
when a tarp went down for planting one
dotted lines is when a tarp went down
for planting to the longer lines is when
a tarp is removed so we don't need to
get too much into this graph I just want
to demonstrate with this that there is
really no pattern in terms of when we
put a tarp down sometimes the tarps went
down on an extremely rainy day sometimes
the tarps went down when there was no
rain and yet by the end of the season or
the end of the tarp duration that is
there was a
difference a uniform difference in soil
moisture based on tarps so about five of
the ten different treatments we had
across plantings and years did have
increased moisture and the most increase
was in Monmouth Maine by far so here we
can see that when it's drier tarps
increased the soil moisture by a lot
more when it's pretty even soil moisture
the tarps didn't really make much of a
difference so River head did not have a
significant difference but River head
also has very sandy soils which probably
had a big impact on that and the more
clay Sophy soils of free bill on Mon
mouth tarps did often significantly
increase the moisture of the soil we
also have a lot of observations from
farmers on this and what they have found
is that the tarps sort of even out the
moisture underneath them and so that
when it's very dry outside the voice
shear under the tarps is much greater
when it's very wet outside so if you
have an extremely heavy rainfall heavy
snow melt water logging of the soil it
is not as waterlogged under the tarps so
they really just create a sort of ideal
moisture environment in which to plant
your crops soil nitrogen was
significantly impacted by tarps nitrate
concentrations increased with tarp
duration but ammonium concentrations did
not so let's look first at nitrate here
we have a graph on the Left showing
nitrate in parts per million in the soil
this is also at 15 centimeters and down
here we have pipe duration and weeks
from no tarp up to 10 or more weeks
again on the Left we have planting one
on the right we have funding - this is
from free though but every single site
showed this exact same pattern in the
dark in the black bars we have pre tarp
nitrate so this was the soil samples
that were taken before we put the tarps
down the gray is showing the nitrate
concentrations after the day that we
took the tarps up and you can see that
when we put the tarps down there was no
difference across the plots and nitrate
when we put the tarps down the longer a
tarp was on the more significantly
increased nitrate concentrations became
in the soil
so why did this happen we have a few
hypotheses one is that nitrate
concentrations increase to do prevention
of leaching nitrate is an extremely
soluble compound and when especially
during the winter when there are no
crops in place to take up that nitrate
when there's snow melt when there's rain
fall that's very easily leached through
the soil
he starts prevents that leaching it's
also possible that that increase in
moisture that increase in temperature
increased microbial activity and
therefore nitrification we have no
evidence of this but these are possible
mechanisms that could have caused that
spike in nitrate under the tarps so
looking into weeds seeds this is still
within the soil environment because
these are seeds that we actually buried
under the tarps so we wanted to see how
tarps impacted the germination of weed
seeds so what we did is we took pigweed
and lambsquarters seeds which are the
two most common weed species that we
encountered in this field and we buried
them in bags and then took them out at
the end of the tarp duration and tested
all the seeds for viability so what we
found from this is that tarps had no
impact on lambsquarters viability but
they actually slightly increased the
viability of pigweed seeds and so what
viability means in this context is that
fewer seeds either germinated or fewer
seeds degraded under the tarps compared
with the bare soil which is not what we
were expecting one possible explanation
for this is that the tarps create an
environment that may have induced
dormancy the tarps may have protected
these weed seeds from exposure to snow
air and sunlight we're not really sure
but I have found literature that found
that pig weed seeds actually will
increase in germination in the dark with
an increase in temperature in nitrate
which we also had so it could have also
been a seasonality thing but we did not
find an increase in via san viability
under tarps but if you look up at this
picture all of these little white
strings those are weed seedlings and so
in one treatment of our tarp this was
the early
planting for free though we found all
this flush of white thread stage
seedlings under the tarp so this does
show that to some extent tarps do induce
germination of seeds and all of these
seedlings were dead from exposure within
one or two hours once they hit the
sunlight and the air so to some degree
tarps can create a sort of stale seed
bed by increasing this germination and
when these seeds germinate and die under
the tarps that's fewer seeds that will
germinate and live in your crop crop
residue was something that we had a very
different result from from what we've
heard so there is at least one study
showing that crops do degrade crop
residue at an increased rate compared
with bare ground we've also heard from
farmers that crop residue is degraded by
tarps we found quite the opposite so
percent cover of crop residue was not
impacted by tarps in fact in some cases
it slightly increased though not
significantly so here you can see a
picture where the tarp was it actually
preserved that cover crop so my pathi
seeds we have for this is that a lot of
farmers will actually lightly till in
the crop residue before tillage or they
will apply compost watering or
amendments which may spike an increase
in the degradation
whereas we just put the tarps directly
over the cover crop yes
you measured crop residue by percent
cover so we had a beaded string that we
put across the plot and each time a
specific point on the string hit a piece
of residue we would count that and then
calculate percent out of 100 so getting
into weeds and crop yield this is a
picture at the about five minutes after
we've taken the tarps off this is for
planting one and this shows the tarp use
of any duration decrease weed percent
cover by 95 to hundred percent so here
we have no tarp and then in the back and
to the right we have our different tarp
treatments there were no living weeds
present under any of these treatments
there was 100% or nearly 100% control of
weeds at the time of removal you can see
the back here is very dark that's just
because of that
over winter residue that's still dark
and green is what's making that color
difference so what happens after 10 days
does this does this increase or does
this I'm sorry go on throughout the
season to have the same effect on the
weeds so in free bill and mon mouth
planting to only harp treatments did
have less weed biomass compared with
bare soil weed counts were never
affected in Riverhead however both weed
mass and weed counts were significantly
reduced by tarps after 10 days so I have
some graphs here to show this this on
the top we have weed count which is per
meter squared for planting one on the
left and planning two on the right and
there is really not much of a pattern so
here down here we have our tillage
treatments none reduced and conventional
so tillage did decrease the counts of
weeds but tarps did not but if you look
on the bottom this is biomass in grams
per meter squared and in planting one we
didn't really have much of an impact
still until you get to reduce and
conventional but planting - we did have
a significant decrease in crop I'm sorry
and weed biomass from the tarps so this
may just be a seasonal variation this
may be because many of the weeds had
already emerged for the planting - and
so when we actually put the tarps down
for planting - the shorter duration
tarps were going down on already emerged
weeds and so that killed everything that
was already there this is a graph from
Riverhead however so as you see here
this is also 10 days later and there was
still almost 100% control of weeds ten
days later as opposed to in freebo so
because of these contrasting results we
wanted to look at the weed species
dynamics so here I have the top five to
six weed species for each site that we
had and I put a start by some of these
because these are the ones that had some
interesting dynamics so first of all
pigweed was extremely prominent and free
though
and in Mon mouth and we actually found
in some treatments that pigweed
increased under tarps this has also been
found in studies with plastic mulch
pigweed is a hoarder of nitrogen so if
you increase nitrate that much for the
tarps especially with the added benefits
of the temperature and the moisture it's
likely to increase in germination red
clover also has a star by it because
this in Mon mouth they had a huge red
clover population it was entirely
decimated by crops here by tarps so
tarps clearly have very species specific
effects for example in free bill common
chickweed was by far the top species in
terms of prevalence but it was also very
well controlled by tarps so when using
tarps on farms you really have to know
what species you have and the tarp
impact on your weed suppression will
depend on what species you have on your
farm so when we started to look at the
interaction between tarps and tillage we
found a very interesting interaction so
this graph is grams per meter squared of
weed biomass in Monmouth Maine on the
bottom here we have tarp duration and 0
up to 10 or more weeks and then tillage
treatments by color so with no tarp and
no tillage you had extremely high weed
counts as one would imagine but the
second you use a tarp your weed counts
decrease rapidly whereas if you look at
the tarp treatments across the reduced
tillage or the conventional tillage
there was very little difference so what
this shows is that by using tarps you
make weed suppression similar between
conventional till no tarp and reduced or
no-till tarp and to illustrate this
further I have a picture here so this is
the plots at the time of harvest on this
column we have on the Left column we
have no tarp on the right column we have
three week tarp and then each of these
is shown for no-till reduced Hill and
conventional till so let's look first at
the no tarp column
as you can see on the top where there's
no tow we had no yield that is all weeds
when you get to reduced Hill we had a
bit more of a yield and when you get to
conventional till we had a full yield
but if you compare that to the column
next to it with the three-week tarp all
of those yields are pretty much the same
and these eels are also comparable to
the conventional till yield and each of
these each of the tarp treatments had
this the three week six week and ten
week had no effect on this so three
weeks was enough to create this effect
so what this means is first of all no
tarp no-till is no yield but if you use
a tarp for three weeks or Beyond it does
show an increased yield benefit so that
graph I showed you with the with the
weed interaction was identical for yield
interaction so tarps did increase crop
yield in the no-till and the reduced
till treatments and made them comparable
to the conventional till treatments so
let's start looking into the farm trials
what I did here is I went to four farms
three of them were around the Finger
Lakes and one was actually in the Hudson
Valley so at each of these farms I
implemented a small version of my
experiment where we worked with the farm
for two beds that they had the same crop
in one bed they would manage as they
would always manage it the second bed
they would manage with tarps and the
only other thing they had to do or the
only thing they had to do was have the
tarp on for at least three weeks
other than that they could leave it on
as long as they wanted they could put
any tillage or other treatments they
wanted so the first firm I worked with
was Centurion farm these farmers tarp
for three to four weeks prior to
planting an onion and a dry bean crop
and this was the farm that really found
a difference in soil moisture so these
found that for the later season dry
beans the tarps were extremely effective
as you know July this year was extremely
dry and so when they put in their crops
or that started in July there was
extremely better yield and stand counts
because of that increased moisture under
the charts they also found
this farm that using a tarp later in the
season was more effective than early in
the season because they planted very
early onions and so that means they took
their tarps off in April early April and
as we saw a lot of the effects of tarps
depend on seasonality and on the outside
temperature so they found the tarps a
lot more helpful for their later season
dry beans the second farm was muddy
fingers fun and for this farm they tarp
for four to five weeks prior to a beet
crop they also found an extreme help in
the moisture in July because this beet
crop did go in in July they had almost
no stand count in July that was not
tarped when they tarped the soil was
moist and it increased their yields even
when they irrigated the non cart beds it
just didn't hold that moisture whereas
the tarp bedstead they also experienced
a very big increase in the degradation
of their cover crop so they used a
sunhemp cover crop and found that by
adding amendments on before the cropping
they significantly reduced their cover
crop at the time of planting the third
farm was plough break farm they used
tarps for five to six weeks prior to a
mixed green crop so this farm found that
when they applied tillage after their
tarps it pretty much negated most of the
benefits it brought up more weed seeds
and actually increased a lot of their
weed pressure they especially had
problems with perennials but when they
told before the tarps it significantly
increased their yields and decreased
their weeds so this is something that we
would like to look more into is if
you're going to apply tillage or
amendments should you do that before
tarping or after tarping and what we
found for most of the growers is they're
actually doing it before tarping as I
said this farm has a really big problem
with perennials especially quackgrass
and they found that tarps really did
decrease their perennial populations so
that is another benefit of tarps that I
haven't really touched on is their
benefit to perennials because we didn't
really have a lot of perennials in our
systems so what these tarps can do is
they can actually decrease the
carbohydrate reserves of these
perennials underneath the tarps and
something that tillage doesn't do so if
you want to get rid of a perennial crop
through tillage you have to continuously
till that until it degrades all of the
carb preserves in those plants but tarps
probably for more than three weeks would
be needed but tarps can if not kill a
perennial crop it can significantly
reduce its viability so we've had
farmers that will have like a huge
infestation of thistle for example and
they find it after tarping for three or
four weeks that thistle is not dead but
it is blanched white it is very weak and
they can pull it up by the taproot
whereas if you tried that before you can
never get at this a lot by its tap roots
and the last form I worked with was
risin root Farm so this is a farm that
is in the Hudson Valley on black dirt so
black dirt is around up to 90 percent
organic matter very high and so these
have this soil has a lot of unique
challenges and dynamics with it so we
wanted to see how tarps impacted this so
this farm used harps for a duration of
three and a half weeks muck soil is
another word for black dirt and they
planted basil cilantro and dill and they
found a significant decrease in weed
pressure even as compared to the local
farms here they found that in their beds
that had no tarping they would have to
weed for two hours within the first two
weeks of planning that crop when they
put used a tarp for that three and a
half week duration they had no weeds
emerge at all so some conclusions from
this experiment tarps can make reduced
tillage more viable in organic vegetable
systems tarps create an ideal soil
environment in which to plant by
increasing soil moisture increasing
temperature and creating a planting bed
free of weeds tarps give a valuable head
start to crop liver weeds so even if
that season-long impact isn't as
impactful from the tarps at least those
first two weeks there are significantly
fewer weeds and that gives any crop
whether it's direct seeded especially or
transplanted a valuable head start over
the competitive weeds we also found that
three weeks was sufficient
to kill weeds and increase yield and
that gives farmers a lot more
flexibility in their cropping plans
weather rather than having to use a tarp
over the entire winter or two receives
those same benefits
so for acknowledgments I would like to
thank my advisor on you of course and
then Ryan and Brian who are here my
handi project team who helped me get all
of this in the field as well as our
partners at Maine and Long Island and my
student interns over the last two years
any questions
[Applause]
very well seminar so thank you I'm
wondering about the reconcile ability of
black plastic with organic methods and
whether plastic is the organic farming
community yes so the question is how
does black plastic work in organic
systems like for from a certification
standpoint and that has been a problem
actually and so until recently black
plastic over winter was not allowed and
organic systems but if it was during the
season it was fine because plastic mulch
is allowed in organic systems but they
said if you leave that tarp on not
during the season so that over winter
it's not a great organic but that was
changed what a couple of weeks ago a
month ago I think was it yeah so it is
actually now certified organic to use a
tarp for any duration of any time
especially since you're taking that tarp
off the field
you're not just leaving it there for the
entire year straight yes so the question
is for the on-farm trials did I collect
the data or did the farmers both sort of
so I actually had the farmers
time themselves for weeding and that was
on them so they would send me their
results but I did do a lot of farm
visits I took a lot of pictures I took a
lot of observations so most of the farm
trials was qualitative data except for
that weeding time which I got from the
farmers Geneva do you have any questions
great talk
one little comment though I think you
are a little hard on solarization weave
when a couple of demos in Cornell and
Cornell and up in Maine finding some
pretty good results and temperatures up
into the 120 s killing a lot of weed
seeds and potentially some pathogens are
any of your your on-farm growers
interested in solarization as well or is
it mostly mostly tarping okay yeah that
was a good question I actually haven't
seen solarization on any of the farms
that I've been to and I couldn't find
any papers that were actually using
solarization in the Northeast so that's
really interesting that it got to
temperature is that high but I haven't
seen them on the farms no beginning you
mentioned this situation so farmers put
drip tape under the plastic mulch
because the mulch stays on during the
growing season when crops are in the
soil so with tarps these come off before
you plant the crop so you do not need to
use drip tape with them the question is
about permeable plastic on top so that
would be something like landscape fabric
and yes landscape fabric is used by a
lot of the farmers so landscape fabric
allows water through it is also reusable
over seasons
well landscape fabric how it's different
from tarps is that it does allow for one
leaching so it doesn't increase that
nitrate it would also kill weeds a lot
more slowly because they are still
getting a measure of sunlight they're
still getting water and weeds can
actually break through that as well so
like nutsedge for example it can break
through the landscape fabric or seeds
can land on top of the landscape fabric
and sprout from there so landscape
fabric is certainly a very good tool to
use but it's but there are different
benefits than parts this is thomas I've
got a question for you you were working
with a lot of on farm trials what do you
see as the best trajectory for the next
couple of years an increasing
implementation of this technique so how
do we want to increase implementation
well I've been talking at a lot of gore
meetings and a lot of farmers are using
this and so the farmers are telling each
other about this for one we've also been
we've been going to present to
conferences like NOFA we've come out
with a tarp fact sheet that we're trying
to get out to farmers I've made a video
on YouTube on the small farms channel
that's explaining to farmers why I use a
tarp how to use a tarp so we're just
trying to get this out a lot more - a
lot more farmers and like I said a ton
of farmers are actually using this
already so at NOFA New York we had a
workshop and 85 farmers came to our
workshop and probably at least 75% of
them were already using tarps on their
farm so this is a very well-established
practice that we're just learning more
about and we are trying to increase
implementation by giving these resources
to farmers and such as like where do you
get a tarp and things like that yes
Hayley what are some scientific
questions that need to be addressed but
you feel yeah so next steps would
definitely be to look more into
mechanisms behind these things that we
found I would say we need to look into
microbial activity under tarps how has
that impacted
is that why nitrate concentrations
increase more on the dynamics certainly
especially looking at individual species
and populations and looking at that
fatal germination so how do tarps
actually impact the seed bank I think
those would probably be the most
important questions along with that
question of when to apply a tillage and
amendments either before or after tarps
yes just as a performance metric have
you thought about looking in soil bone
density or some indicator or soil
structure you know which is kind of the
poster child for my village destroys yes
so the question was have we looked at
bulk density no that definitely would be
interesting I'm not sure how tarps would
in fact that that's more of a tillage
metric which has been studied in depth
but it is possible that tarps could
could impact that but we did not look at
that yes your lethal germination
question have you found differences
between differences in weed populations
or prevalence between tilling event
tarping versus just our pennies we had
found the apples which is a very
different system that we had more annual
weeds yes so the question is annuals
versus perennial weeds different species
on tilling versus tarping with no
tillage yes okay yeah so we definitely
did find a big difference in weed
species there so what I found I did do
counts by species when I did the counts
and so what I found there was that in
the no-till treatments there was a huge
variety of weeds a lot of perennials
like you said and annuals and just a
huge diversity whereas in the till plots
it was 90 percent lambs quarters and
pig-pig weed and those are annuals so
tillage dust definitely has the effect
of bringing those seeds up and actually
increasing the germination of some of
those after we did not tarp after
tillage so that is a practice that's
being used and but that is not the
practice that we studied so we actually
told after
but that would definitely be an
interesting question this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu